22 seconds of hard to see paragraphs of
obituary reading only did they already
remake downsizing okay come on let's go
well late maybe next time week the kids
up before the mother gets at a car
funeral creeps they're not glad Charlie
could inappropriately eat a chocolate
bar at a grandma's funeral so that fake
Keyser söze could bring up her allergies
also child in a horror movie has asthma
or peanut allergy that will factor into
the plot later cliche if I've learned
anything from my countless hours of CSI
viewing it's that if you make miniatures
here a serial killer pretty sure there's
no gray area here also come on Annie
small world you've got to do better than
that if your whole milieu is miniature
art couldn't you literally call
everything you do small world playing
with yourself I read a scary also was
that a ghost er was Annie just seeing
things if you expect the movie to shed
any light on this you're we know that
this actually happened Annie's mom
breastfed Charlie but how that must have
been one epic breast pumping to keep it
going through her menopausal years in
some 30 years after the last time she
gave birth Peter fails miserably at the
Bechdel test sorry she probably gets
this all the time but we're an often
lowbrow film and animation channel so we
have to go there you know for the kids
so does that make it more tragic or less
tragic than if he has a choice one thing
you can always count on in horror movies
one of the main characters will be
learning about something in literature
that will be important to their own
lives later of course who can blame
boner for getting a Peter in class and
not paying attention care to weigh in
Peter why is Peter still even looking at
his phone is it really taking him this
long to read want a smoke a bullet break
if so maybe he should have held off on
that bowl before brick movie is clearly
trying to make Charlie the creepy kid in
the family but Peter is making a very
good case for himself staring daggers
into Bridget's back I mean it's not like
charlie is off eating chocolate while
staring at a dead bird I mean carry on
yeah Chad Owen
he does at school and notices a creepy
person staring at them across the street
in a horror movie cliche dad it's the
cemetery why would the cemetery ask for
Steve specifically when revealing the
news about auntie's mom's grave being
desecrated maybe he paid for the funeral
but that means elsewhere in the movie
world Bruce Wayne we get a call about
Clark Kent's grave being desecrated
instead of Martha may be common sense is
in the cemeteries for tech I didn't let
her anywhere near me when I had my first
my son we find out later that the King
Peyman cult is super manipulative with
the ability to control Annie's family's
fate to a high degree and that payment
wants a male vessel to possess so why
did they fail so hard when Peter was
born I just don't want to put any more
stress on my family I'm not even really
sure if they could Pony King Collette we
will see this mysterious light a few
times in the movie and it's supposedly
the spirit of King Peyman we see later
when Peter gets possessed but I thought
his spirit was living inside Charlie the
spirits have to go on smoke breaks - I
can see why this picture would be taken
after all it's grandma feeding the new
baby but grandma and the baby look so
dead inside I highly doubt that it would
be hung on the refrigerator this email
gives a reply all option even though
Sylvia archer sent this only to Annie
and Gmail simply doesn't give this
option under those circumstances this is
definitely the worst mistake in the
movie and I'm going to add a hundred no
wait just one I'm sorry I misunderstood
what Satan was asking you can I take
your sister mom goes to incredible
lengths to make sure Charlie doesn't
drink by making him take his way younger
sister to a high school party she
suspects like any good mom one that
drinking will be taking place there but
- sighs that this will be a safe
environment for a 13 year old daughter
to experience and yeah I know about the
creepy cult that apparently controls
their actions we will get to that later
but for now sip this symbol is
everywhere and it's a neat touch
explaining the cultists reach but come
on to be able to figure out what Charlie
and Peter are going to do it every
minute I'd love to see them plan their
spouts seriously this movie is 67%
foreshadowing let's just walk over and
stand there I'll give you peace I get
the Peter wants to go not impress
Bridget with more of his not so smooth
talk but he couldn't think of anything
better to distract Charlie with not only
does she have the nut allergy to worry
about but this is a fucking high school
party it could be fucking pot in that
cake which is exactly why he doesn't
want her to go with him to the bedroom
Charlie seems old enough to know to ask
whether or not there were nuts in this
cake and since this is pretty much the
inciting incident for the rest of the
movie it's sin worthy okay for the
record what happens to this poor girl is
absolutely awful but this is also the
ultimate cock lock nut allergy block
it's hard to breathe
also hard to believe that when Annie Mae
bring his sister to this thing she
didn't make him bring the EpiPen they to
EpiPens just in case and we were already
told that they forgot to bring one with
them to the funeral at the beginning of
the movie
I guess heard a nut allergy isn't that
big of a deal because this family is
terrible I guess to get this beheading
just right so that Peter would swerved
at the telephone pole the payment
followers went with the killing of a
sacred deer even though Peter never
answered his mom's phone call during the
party and that she was worried about
them and that going to a party like this
would be a big moment in Charlie's life
that she'd want to hear about Annie
conveniently for the movie stays in the
bedroom so that she can discover the
horrific sight of her headless daughter
in the morning also I get that Peter is
in shock but he doesn't even try to
superglue his sister's head back onto
her body isn't that what all the kids do
in these comedy is when they break
something priceless at a party risky
business anyone one and a half minutes
of crying cemetary has a convenient plot
open for dramatic camera movements
directly across from the burial taking
place on screen Jesus a heater makes the
entire room glow a shade of red that you
could see from space hi I'm Lydia
luckily for the plot the paymon light
spills blue paint on Jones phone number
so that she'll call and go visit her
it's entirely outside her character to
seek help like this but she does it for
the movies sake maybe she has no choice
maybe she's being drawn to these actions
by the cult but it seems like they leave
a lot to chance I mean I guess they know
and it will call John just because she
sees the number art I wish I could
shield you from the knowledge that you
did what you did but your sister is dead
the scene is so visceral and everyone's
so amazing in it I'm removing three sins
the United States of Annie so was this a
medium the talk Joan had to be a medium
because that doesn't seem good for
business and Annie doesn't ask yourself
how does this woman know how to do
seances after a medium did it for just
once Annie would be terrible at cinema
sit I don't know what language it is the
medium had me read it first if you don't
know what language it is then how do you
know how to pronounce the words and she
doesn't even tell her how to say them or
where she leaves skirt
let it never be said that this movie
didn't try to Gaslight us
Annie wakes up Steve to do the seance
but why does this have to take place at
1:45 in the morning seance portion of
the film is the idiotic
and he pulls this off like a seasoned
Miss Cleo 20 minutes ago and it didn't
need to do this is a family this is all
our energies okay together except you
just said you did it by yourself 20
minutes ago so why do you need them hey
that earlier I think I need to read that
again clever a movie doesn't even make
her say the thing that is obviously
impossible to say it's a good way of
skirting the issue what language is even
that I can ask the same thing so
apparently this is the ritual by which
the cult gets payment to leave charlie
and move to Peter but this opens up way
more questions like where did payment go
after Charlie died if this ritual is to
bring payment into the house why doesn't
it go inside Peter right away all he
needs is the most vulnerable vessel and
we've seen Peter he's at his lowest
right now on the page I thought why
didn't we see any of what Annie did
before she invited the family to try it
are we supposed to be as skeptical as
they are this is a kind of frustrating
part of the movie to sit through
honestly because there seems to be no
point in why they didn't show us her
first draw all the performances are very
good in this movie even great at times
but this Cry moment is the worst
this movie does plant many clues that
foreshadow later events but none of the
writing on the walls is ever explained
like the director just threw them in for
sheer creep factor since Annie has been
spending some of her nights in the
treehouse I'm not sure why Steve has to
be cocked commando also this is taking
nothing away from Tony Colette's
performance but I feel like Gabriel
Byrne might be the Tom Cruise from Rain
Man in this picture and it is giving a
much better performance than he's
getting credit for and that is a sin so
that turned out not to be Charlie's head
but what made the ball fall from the
wall you were pulling my head - B -
think this when he never saw who was
pulling on his head sure there was
supposedly a time when Annie nearly set
he and Charlie on fire but that doesn't
mean she's the type to pull on someone's
head
I love how Annie's first thought is I
tried to burn the book and now I'm
burning because of it rather than any
other reason her sleeve might be burning
right now sure she couldn't get the fire
out earlier when she was slapping at it
but did she seriously think she'd put
out the fire with that weak attempt and
steve is a sound sleeper Annie might
want to check on him after she's done
putting the fire out he might be dead oh
my god Joan's involved in this said no
one and was ever seen a movie before
also what is all this we got a broken
pencil some sticks a couple animal heads
some balls with temples from sunglasses
attached a whole bevy of what the yeah
it's a diorama of what happens at the
end of the movie but lady buy some
Barbie and Ken dolls what'd you do with
them afterwards is your business Peter
get so can no one hear her except Peter
and if so could the movie show us
something so we can understand this this
movie makes Twin Peaks look like Blue's
Clues it was really nice of Mommy
Dearest to highlight and underline the
most crucial things that Annie would
need to know that's called thinking
ahead and just like everything else it's
all about putting money this is
essentially Ocean's eleven with
crazy-ass witches so Annie's mom knew
Joan and they were a part of this cult
together they sure left a lot to chance
when they came up with this plan didn't
a good thing Annie found this only when
it was too late and also why did they
take so many goddamn pictures of
themselves doing all this especially
this where it's clear Annie's family as
a target also it's a photograph of a
photograph
Nickelback would be so proud and Def
Leppard and all the verified good the
movie not come up with a better ghostly
effect than the one that just looks like
a cigarette burn conveniently Annie
finds the body right after she found all
her late mom's pictures in satanic
literature also Steve clearly didn't
decide to investigate the strange smell
from a few days ago any further and
everyone was fine with it despite the
renowned smell of corpses
your social life does not recover from
this by the way you dug up the grave all
those nights you're pretending to go to
the movies you mean Steve really thinks
a nice nook out dug a little bit of her
mother's grave everyday and the cemetery
didn't notice until the body been taken
out in the fire
I get the cheese grasping at straws but
how is she so certain destroying this
book will stop King payment and why does
she think it won't attack Steve if he
throws it in the fire like it did her he
was also with her when she contacted
truck even when you're watching a movie
like hereditary which tries to elevate
itself above typical horror movies
scenes like this were the crazy but not
crazy but maybe a little crazy person
tries to make the other person believe
what they believe without any reason or
logic can't be downright exhausting to
watch watching Annie plead with her
rightfully disbelieving husband becomes
a chore I mean I've been watching what's
happening and I don't even believe her
and I bet we could do a bonus round on
how many pleases have been set in this
movie but we die there's already a fire
to throw the book into pouring gasoline
on top of it just seems like overkill
Gabriel Byrne also if she threw a 10 why
is Steve now on fire the first time she
threw it in it set her on fire and only
started with her sleeve so why did Steve
go all Brad Dourif and spontaneously
combust
wait is Peyman inside her body now I
wish I knew what the light was if it's
actually Peyman or curly or some other
demon the motherfucker can't make up its
mind don't mind me I'm just hanging up
here in the corner of your room I
debated on what would be creepier this
or peeing in the middle of your bedroom
I decided on this what do you think why
is Peter taking such a long goddamn time
to walk down those stairs oh I don't
care how tough that nose is he should at
least be getting a whiff of the barbecue
burn right about now bye Danny
spider-man II does whatever a spider and
he does damn I haven't seen Gabriel burn
this chart and toasted since the usual
suspects
could she get up here while I believe
that these cultists could set up some
spiritual and psychological I do not
believe they could make a body transport
through the ceiling to set up the scary
image if they can do this they can
literally do anything
Peter survives this one thing I learned
from these movies is that demonic
deities do not like people with clothes
on also Peter just realized he walked
next door to the set of the next human
centipede sequel hey Jim
heard you were an hereditary who'd you
play homie I was one of those guys
kneeling in the tree house with my dick
hanging out it was awesome
Charlie - Joan calling Peter Charlie now
even if there's an explanation for this
isn't he now King payment why bother
with any name other than that one we've
corrected your first female body and
give you now this healthy male host why
did it take 13 15 years to do this
though also the insane number of things
that had to go right for these King
payment followers to get Peter to be the
host is impossible maybe every step of
this plan was manipulated in some way so
that they would succeed but think about
what they had to do they had to somehow
make sure Peter brought Charlie to the
party she need a piece of cake with nuts
in it have an allergic reaction have
Peter speed towards a hospital and run
his sister's head into a pole while
Charlie's stuck her head out to breathe
have Amy run in a Joan of the support
group have Annie call Joe when paint
spilled on her phone number believe John
when she said she could talk to spirits
have any freak out about a book of
drawings have her convinced the book
absolutely needed to be burned and trick
her into trying again only to burn Steve
instead make Peter investigate
downstairs and run to the Attic
eventually throwing himself out the
window and finally make him weak enough
that payment could finally possess his
body and I don't even think I've gotten
all the stuff even with that long-ass
rant you might say well the coat would
have found another way if this wasn't
the one and I say good maybe it won't
take so long next time
and baldness is hereditary no don't give
a second thought as to who's gonna pay
the mortgage we'll just leave it all up
to Carolyn you mean you're gonna take
care of everything now Carolyn yes
it's cancer right I Drive a Dodge
Stratus you're gonna love my nuts Peter
get Oh too bad we can't stay babe